foreign
[Music]
my wife and I are divorcing because I
got her Frenemy pregnant a friend to me
I wasn't expecting that go on wife
agreed I could live in the basement
until I find a place the walls are thin
I hear her with a male friend and she
was never that loud and wild with me I'm
dying inside what do I do
where do you find these you found the
last one as well didn't you like this
yeah wow
so let me let me say again yes bro life
and I are divorcing because I got her
friend and me pregnant
wife agreed I could live in the basement
until I find a place the walls are thin
I hear her with a male friend and she
was never wild and loud with me I'm
dying inside what do I do
what do you do James what do you do you
do I got her a friend of me pregnant
friending me that see it's always the
mandums
why all people yeah because it's
forbidden bro we know why yeah but like
pregnant yeah yeah he won't pull it out
though man the friend of me if the
frenemy's moving to you and she's moving
mad and you're not used to this kind of
female yeah and it's forbidden yeah and
she said I'm not telling us so I'm
telling the soul and I'm sitting on it
and then she does and then she just says
leave it in I'll bite my bottom lip off
[Laughter]
um
nine out of ten men ain't strong enough
to pull out of that
being strong enough she couldn't be on
top right of me she couldn't she
couldn't be on top right in me yeah yeah
yeah she's a rap bro it's a rap and then
you're there just like oh [ __ ] you're in
the basement just like dealing with what
you need to deal with and your wife's
getting crap
noise upstairs
and she doesn't she doesn't even let she
doesn't let the man that she's banging
no oh my ex is downstairs yeah they're
just crazy the walls are thin they just
crack on
and that's what I do
yo and she's just ah
Papi Chulo yeah oh God no no no no no no
I'll bang on the walls scream a scream
Bethany
stop
please
and I might be like who's downstairs
what is that what or who was that he
also hear me scratching up the walls
please don't do this don't worry about
that base don't worry about who that is
downstairs why are you listening to next
man clap me Focus I couldn't hear that
that I couldn't have that either why are
you listening to next man get a business
if I'm the my man upstairs I am in a
different realm do you know do you know
do you know do you know um oh my God
okay so now imagine all the things he
could be hearing yeah okay so like it's
only oh so obviously a man's voice
resonates in walls yeah that bass
resonates yeah yeah and that's when we
go back to that where's that gag reflex
imagine that I thought he was imagine
you're hearing nothing and all you hear
is my man say Jesus I thought you said
you had a gag reflex
I think I would find a way because
obviously in the basement there's like
pillars right yeah I'm breaking the
pillow down so the whole the whole
Foundation yeah Will concave and we'll
all die because I can't hear stuff like
that no it's one of them ones wear
she only lets you out she only lets you
out like twice a day upstairs so
obviously you need to cook you need to
do this you need to so you go upstairs
when the yard is free obviously Mama's
not there and you just you just get that
sting you just get that whip because you
know how you know
you you smell so foreign
eucalyptus and dragon fruit and you're
like damn it's not good yes son of a
[ __ ] bro and you'll just stay in the
kitchen trying to cook some and she just
strolls downstairs you know them flowy
dressing gowns silk thing and then she
just literally just kisses her teeth and
walks back upstairs she's jiggling when
she walks upstairs
James I will pull somebody needs a
beggar take me back I'll back her take
me back because I can't listen to that
don't let him in here again please if
you ever loved me do this one thing
don't let him in here sorry I will start
singing outside the window outside our
window on some boy's dementia I promise
you oh my God
nah ask just clap I was jiggling just
jiggling up the stairs and you know you
can't touch that again oh [ __ ] I'll cry
my eyes out bro men aren't built for
this kind of pain we can't we actually
can't handle it because this is all
hypothetical and I'm suffering well I I
feel like I'm in the basement yeah this
is my wife we're talking about
I'm there I'm him fam and I've not even
thought about the friend of me once it
was a mistake [ __ ] it was a mistake
who who are we talking about big man who
are we talking about I love you it's
just me and you stop and the dreading is
is the nut that you gave to friend of me
is nowhere near the Clapping that you
always been getting on a day today see
what I'm saying brother it's not fair
it's just not fair because she doubled
down my wife doubled down because she
knew I'm gonna hear it and I'm going to
be livid
nah nah that's that's the worst
experience I can imagine bro I wouldn't
wish that on my worst enemy because
Amanda obviously I'm not saying girls
can't handle that kind of stuff but
Amanda really can't they're recording
cameras here we go
we really really can't so women please
just stop go easy on us because
sometimes like I'm saying he that friend
anything's too forbidden yeah yeah it's
not even it's his fault but it's really
out of his control now this one is Alvis
hands
I'm not going to tell a soul I'll sit on
it and I won't tell a soul and she just
climbs on it's one of them when she just
lift up the skirt and just climbs on it
says fill me up
literally you're like yeah but my canine
will pierce my lip
fill me up Daddy
don't stop fill me up I can't hear stuff
yet exactly and now we're we're out
where we're at okay we're here yeah
she's pregnant she's pregnant yeah like
what do you want me to do it was her but
it was literally all her fault and now I
have to live in the gutter listening to
what sounds like Eureka moments
you read the moments
oh like we're learning stuff upstairs oh
bro we're experimenting a lot and he's
he's so aggressive with you he is and
that's this is a man of a certain color
but I can't believe one of the ones
where you've got the dangling light in
the basement
and this is like the dust spraying from
the roof
I just look it up to the heavens like
why me
my my ex-wife wife whatever would
probably come downstairs two days later
and find my body on the floor
up this swinging thing would be wrapped
around my neck
because I can't take another second of
listening to this I can't I'm not I
physically can't bro that's what I'm
saying ladies please
sometimes we really do mess up you do
but don't do us down yeah
and we really can't handle it like I'm
feeding this guy right now I can't
handle it who had [ __ ] I can't handle it
I can't hand it I also won't be able to
tell us so what's going on in my own
house
I couldn't tell him what are you doing
get out factual but you were like a gun
or bring a Ting round and the thing is
I'll be like you don't get the last
thing I wanted to bring it I miss her
this is how much pain I'm in yeah I love
her so much I wouldn't even dare bring a
thing round
she's getting banned upstairs I still
wouldn't dare bring a thing around I
wouldn't dare I need her back yeah well
I can't get my words I wouldn't be able
to confiding you with that yeah
that's it and your only out is to go
back to a frenemy
a peaceful night's sleep
ah she hollers you like if you ever need
a chain of scenery come free I can keep
a nicer warm for you
and you just think you're just one day
you just can't take it yeah it's the
only light in a dark dark tunnel darkest
tunnel yeah the darkest times it's the
only light and you go there the shame
you'd feel after that
re-banging
you're now pregnant
and now you have to sleep here oh yeah
she's trying to cuddle you get a PNC
found that PNC will hit you like a
Haymaker like a Mike Tyson hey make it
to the jaw yeah get your hands off of me
I want my wife fan I want my wife
that's all I'll be saying to her I came
over to tell you that I want my wife
no no that's making a difference because
your wife's getting a head caved in I
hope
nah that is a level of Revenge I don't
wish on anybody
because I'm breaking the foundation yeah
of the yard and it's concave symbolism
because this is what's my soul's going
through right now is what my rib cage is
doing facts and I hope it kills me quick
yeah quick and seamless quick and
seamless and I hope my man upstairs gets
dangling bam and mandem will
foreign
this is Harsh and dark but it's so true
Manda will contemplate hurting
themselves just to make her care a bit
I'm saying
in that scenario Amanda will because he
can't actually die because he won't be
able to see yeah yeah what happens yeah
but like he wants to take himself close
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah men are so
toxic like this like with that level of
Revenge he can't handle it yeah yeah
yeah he'll happily paralyze himself just
to see if you'll come to the hospital
yeah imagine and then when you do it's
all worth it
you're like I want now you're back she's
backing about it because she has to take
care of me yeah she has to she has to
for better off alone sorry I'm sorry and
you're gonna have to raise this you
you're gonna have to and man it was so
horrible as well because give it two
years she's back with you you have guilt
yeah she's not banging my man anymore
she's not banging you because you can't
do [ __ ] she's raising you you're you're
illegitimate you yeah and you're there
kissing your teeth watching football bro
where's my crisps where are they you
know I can't feed myself live with just
their mouth open yeah I'm the one who's
paralyzed why are you complaining help
me
help me for better for us right help me
change change my catheter what is this
what kind of service is this do you love
me or not oh my God yeah my name is the
worst yeah but yeah you can't put some
you can't you can't put someone through
that
[Music]